nous sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés un
philippe pilato le directeur du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors philippe qu'est ce que ça
représente le linxea ffgolf pour le golf
national de saint-quentin du leem mais
pour nous c'est une belle opportunité
c'est vrai que de recevoir recevoir ce
tournoi sur cette semaine semaine qui
était qui était dédié à l'open de france
c'était c'est une excellente nouvelle
pour pour pour l'ensemble des équipes
parce qu'en fait le site a été conçu
pour pouvoir recevoir des compétitions
de haut niveau des compétitions
professionnelles compétitions amateurs
de haut niveau et retrouver un petit peu
l'élite l'élite française sur le site du
golf national c'est une lingette chose
d'extraordinaire ça s'est fait un petit
peu la dernière minute ça s'est passé
comment ben en fait ça s'est passé que l
open de france l'open de france est
reportée dans le calendrier donc mais on
avait cette semaine l'actualité un jeu
précieux à la crise sanitaire et donc
voilà donc on avait une semaine vacante
des équipes mobilisées sur l'événement
un parcours qui avait été commencé à
préparer on avait on avait préparé le
parcours de façon à ce qu'ils soient
opérationnels pour l'open de france est
donc en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la fédération a trouvé à trouver un
sponsor sponsors qui s'est positionné de
façon à pouvoir accueillir cet événement
ça permet au golf national de continuer
un petit peu sa vie d'avant si je peux
dire d'avoir des compétitions de haut
niveau
bah oui oui c'est exactement ça c'est
vrai que l'ensemble des collaborateurs
sur le terrain c'est vrai que ça donne
ça donne un objectif
dans l'année ça permet de mobiliser les
équipes ça permet de sortir un petit peu
de sa zone de confort et de proposer de
proposer quelque chose
enfin un produit qui est en tout cas un
parcours qui est qui est fin prêt pour
accueillir ce tournoi oui vous le disiez
les jardiniers tous ceux qui s'attachent
à rendre ce golf national si beau
voulait absolument des compétitions
aussi c'est important pour les employés
du golf national
bah oui c'est important parce qu'en fait
on est on a été éduqué dopé aux
compétitions de haut niveau c'est vrai
qu'on a eu la chance d'accueillir
beaucoup de fun de france d'accueillir
les championnats de france des jeunes
des championnats d'europe
les championnats du monde la ryder cup
en 2018 hélas d'accueillir des
événements tels que linxea pour nous
c'est ça permet vraiment de redonner un
objectif et un coup de boost aux équipes
ou et le ningxia sais c'est quoi
finalement c'est une compétition
franco-française déjà mouais exactement
c'est à dire qu'en fait ça rassemble un
champ
d'amateurs en champs de professionnels
des messieurs des dames et c'est pour ça
que c'est un événement extra fins qui
est fabuleux je trouve parce que
vraiment il ya une mixité il ya les
différents publics il ya des jeunes il
ya des très jeunes
il ya on a le numéro 2 français qui est
là on antoine ros nerfs qui est qui qui
est là pour partager on va dire pour se
préparer pour partager et faire des
partages d'expériences entre berre des
amateurs de bon niveau qui se lancent et
puis des joueurs professionnels qui eux
sont déjà lancées sur lesquels on attend
beaucoup justement antoine ros heures
c'est un petit peu là on va tirer tête
d'affiche de cet événement numéro 2
français vous vous me le dire il a été
notamment états unis il a réussi
brillante performance face à bredene de
chamboule le numéro 5 mondial
il a battu c'était important de la voir
aujourd'hui sami la lumière sur cet
événement
bah oui ça m'aide à lumière ça mais la
fierté ça donne moi je trouve ça en tant
que structure fédérale le site de la
fédération française de golf d'avoir le
numéro 2 français qui est présent sa
porte de l'intérêt et je trouve que
réellement et sam est réellement une
lumière sur l'événement et je pense que
pour toutes les personnes qui sont là
qui sont dans le champ des joueurs de
pouvoir avoir antoine ros nerfs à côté
de ces je pense que c'est vraiment une
plus value pour le oui alors et les
conditions sont un petit peu compliqué
aujourd'hui est ce que vous attendez une
météo si compliqué pour les prochains
jours non non non non normalement c'est
aujourd'hui on a un temps un temps
breton ou écossais et après ça va
s'améliorer avec des conditions qui
devraient être bonnes demain avec du
beau temps demain et je crois que samedi
on doit avoir plus de 20 degrés dimanche
enfin bon dit les joueurs seront plus à
dimanche mais en tout cas dimanche il
devrait faire très très beau seul souci
sur sur cet événement c'est forcément
l'absence du public
on a tous dû faire des tests pcr pour
venir ici on est journaliste vous êtes
organisateur mais il n'y a pas de public
ici est ce que c'est un regret ouais
c'est toujours un regret c'est vrai que
deux voilà lorsqu'on laisse qu'on met
beaucoup d'énergie
à préparer des événements lorsqu'on met
beaucoup d'énergie à préparer les
terrains on met en a envie de partager
c'est vrai que là on partage pas m'aimer
mais il n'empêche que il n'empêche que
le principal c'est de pouvoir donner la
possibilité à des joueurs professionnels
et de joueurs amateurs de pouvoir jouer
c'est la priorité
est ce que vous êtes plutôt optimiste
quand même sur le retour du public ici
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
disons que là jusqu'à présent on en a on
a dû passage on a beaucoup de passagers
je remercie l'ensemble des personnes qui
voilà qui viennent jouer chez nous on a
nos parcours qui les parcours de
l'albatros et les parcours de l'aigle on
a vraiment beaucoup de fréquentation et
et ça jusqu'à présent très honnêtement
voilà on peut pas se plaindre parce que
on a eu des conditions météo qui était
extraordinaire des parcours qui sont
dans des conditions aussi exceptionnel
l'albatros donc comme jouer y compris
par depuis longtemps pour l'open de
france est donc là qui est prêt pour le
linxea et le parcours de l'aig sur
lequel on met beaucoup d'attention le
linxea ça sera une seule édition ici au
golf national où ça pourrait s'inscrire
ici au golf national dans l'est dans les
prochaines années là dessus je ne sais
pas mais je pense que après derrière
c'est format de tournoi je trouve que
des tournois qui à la fois rassemble les
meilleurs joueurs amateurs français
qui se destinent à une belle carrière
amateur ou alors une très belle carrière
professionnelle et les meilleurs
professionnels français
je pense que c'est une belle chose oui
tout à fait et donc si on peut inscrire
sa au calendrier pourquoi pas dans la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
à cet événement ce week-end la météo ce
qu'on peut souhaiter c'est une meilleure
météo non mais la météo sera bienvenue
sera bien meilleure ce qu'on peut
souhaiter céder des joueurs qui prennent
beaucoup de plaisir à jouer sur sur le
parcours de l'albatros des amateurs qui
prennent beaucoup d'expérience des
joueurs professionnels mais qui vont
prendre des gains grâce grâce aux
sponsors et comme le disait antoine j'ai
eu la chance de parler avec lui hier il
me disait que c'était un excellent est
en test et antoine heureuse nerfs un
excellent test c'est une bonne
préparation pour le spd est donc si ça
lui permet de bien se préparer pour
perfé à l'usb jim ça serait une belle
semaine il vous remerciera peut-être à
la fin du tournoi loi ouais non mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'il se remercier à
lui malgré tout à fait merci beaucoup
aux philippines à tout